this reviews coming late I know I'm
sorry the conjuring - we have to talk
about it we do we have to because the
movie is just too damn good for us to
not give our two cents I mean if you
haven't heard already it's a good movie
I think like everybody likes it for the
most part no it's adult it's it's a
weird like it's a delightful movie this
one I did have a great time watching it
I think from beginning to end this
script is really tightly woven everybody
scene is pretty much essential to the
whole story you really care about the
characters it's gripping it's terrifying
at times there's some unique shots I
don't want you to say anything I try to
cover all the ground there's some great
music and James Wong he did it again he
made it even better it's great acting
Thursday that great great producing
sound design was excellent you thought
yeah beyond sound what would you like to
say I really like gon drink - I I mean
uh the first conjuring was a movie that
I saw and I thought was really good and
I didn't love as much as everybody else
I feel like I should go back and
re-watch it cuz I was like I I remember
liking it but going to this movie I was
going kind of cold I really enjoyed this
I mean this one is bigger and crazier
than the first movie there's definitely
a lot more like aggressive supernatural
[ __ ] yeah I think it's a much more
defined film in terms of it like being
in the horror genre because I've been
hearing some people say how the film is
how the first contouring was more of
just you know my god damn it was it was
not much more than just a horror movie
whereas this one is still a film it's
just there's a lot more horror which is
great because that's and the conjure in
the first movie felt more like a classic
haunting movie whereas this one feels
and intentionally he said he wanted to
return the quality of studio a big
studio horror and so this is more of a
big studio horror movie like The
Exorcist or Rosemary's Baby yeah this is
Alice whistles his most expensive
or our families ever done yeah so I feel
like the first movie has just more of a
classic restrained approach than this
one yep kind of and this one you know
goes hog wild
I like how they didn't copy the same
kind of you know beach heat for the
conjuring - they did manage to raise the
stakes an awful lot especially when it
came to the warrens
I like how the first half does what the
first half of the contouring does which
is a focuses on this specific family and
this is a different kind of family it's
not like you got the same heart types
here they're all they're very good
family you know they really British they
seem familiar British natural together
that's like did they write this the
woman who plays the mother in this I
thought was terrific ratio she was like
on edge a lot to tell she really loved
her kids and and I feel like that's
something James Bond's really good out
in these kinds of movies too cuz because
he's good at setting up a family that
feels like a real family like she was
gonna intercut with my sorry I have a
point I don't remember now I said this
this and and then you just went boom
gonna interrupt now I forgot my point it
was gonna be the greatest point of this
review this was gonna be the part of the
review people like I like that part
where Greg said how awesome conjuring 2
is in this particular department I'm
running the reveal it really changes the
course you've ruined the review alright
1 million subscribers oh I wanted to say
you know he's like she's just mean
enough to her kids to the point where
you're like she's not abusive oh yeah
totally I mean you get that she's
stressed and she's tired but the end of
the day she still really does care some
of the best scenes in the movie for me
are between the daughter who's who's
being possessed and the mother like
that's the most intense part of that
family relationship and like those
scenes are great yeah those really hit
and I like how the these these kids did
seem relatable and real yeah like they
seemed like real people full-time so the
girl who played Janet Madison wolf was
amazing I heard she's American yeah she
is yeah that's crazy
it's like Q&A with them those like the
British actors are the best
the British actors are the best she was
very believable you really believed her
in these terrible situations or a
deterioration of this girl going through
this little girl who like is being
possessed by them doesn't know why she's
doing these weird thing like she's
really natural then there's some scenes
where she just has to be straight-up
terrified I'm like you believe her
really 13 years old too
but what I really like to loved about
this film was although it was really a
scary and had this theme of love in
there that was great like that it wasn't
corny to me it was it felt really
inspired hanging in a lot of ways
especially when it dealt with the
warrants get a sense more of where the
relationship is that now they're a lot
more popular than on TV shows a lot more
you get a sense of Parenthood a lot more
with them - yeah you get to know their
lives and and that makes the stakes
bigger for them as characters
I love these characters I love them even
more I thought they were amazing in the
first one they're the best part of the
movie of me and now this one I'm like I
really feel like I know them more now
and I care more for the Warrens as a
unit you know yeah and I did prior like
I want these two to be together because
they work perfectly together and I'm
totally on board to watch part 3 oh yeah
totally I mean their connection in their
love story is something that enhances
this movie and it and that is you know
something I think James Wan has done a
good job of making a really good studio
style you know
big money horror movie because it has
all the sweeping emotions you know it's
like there is a strong love story with
the Warrens there's a strong family
story there are a lot of scares and
there's so much fantasy stuff like it
has a little bit everything you'll laugh
you'll cry old cast it does that with
like a really genuine feeling very
honest story shot very very well there's
some crazy unique shots yeah awesome
editing it breaks a lot of horror movie
cliches and a lot of times when you
think something's gonna be predictable
or you know sometimes he goes the things
faster and a story than you you thought
it might go like there's a lot of good
surprises like you'll tilt a key down
past where you're like well I mean he's
really good at crafting scares and about
making you care for the characters which
are two things you need and and I mean
especially ghosts and demons you're
gonna have a lot of jump scares and
stuff like that and the jumps in this
movie are creative and creepy in context
and stuff like that in it and he's got a
really good sinister tone around yeah
it's not filled with it and I think the
jump scares often feature unique shots
too oh yeah that's the cool thing of why
it's not like Oh a jump scare because
it's not like typical like okay when the
camera pans over here there's gonna be
this there was this one part in the
trailer that did scare me that seemed
like it was just doing that with her in
the mirror but
yeah well there's a shot after that very
moment that they cut away from in the
trailer like the very next shot is a
really cool shot yeah that was those
evens that made it even scarier yeah
yeah well and I've but even that like
even taking the time to make a jump
scare in-camera with you know whip pans
and stuff that makes it feel more real
and it's more scary because you know a
lot of jump scares are just hitting and
editing you know we just come to
something really quick you know exact
about know is you know of course you're
gonna get people to jump but this one
you know he does a lot of stuff in
camera or as much in camera as possible
it makes everything feel so much
creepier you know there's some little
details that depart into like the
fantastical realm especially with one
you know kind of spooky character which
I really loved about this so it might
seem a little out of place that yes it
was one of my favorite
I love the crook and I really feel like
the you know like the concept of how you
have to fight the demons would love is
yeah well I mean it is that sort of like
older school it's like you know there's
the purity of your soul you know the
light you need to use your light you
know to cast out the dark force yeah you
know but it doesn't go into like cheesy
corny territory yeah yeah and isn't
going to Anne Hathaway and interstellar
talking about love it's dealing with the
story at hand and everybody on the
screen is you know a person and capable
well I'm gonna give it a consensus
because I don't believe in ratings and
I'm hoping like you know this makes it
easier to feature my name on trailers
and stuff whatever the conjuring - it
takes horror in a direction that
satisfies moviegoers I think the
conjuring - is a great return of studio
horror and a really well-made haunted
house moon news channels i've never real
rejects John Jerry sand so so manager of
people left loon house facebook follow
us on networks and you have a good night
take care now